whether it's climate change or the
coronavirus pandemic
president trump repeatedly rejects
advice from
specialists he refuses to follow the
science
well scientists have apparently decided
it is no longer
enough to let the facts speak for
themselves this week
scientific american the oldest magazine
in the u.s
ended a 175-year policy of staying out
of presidential
politics the magazine's editor-in-chief
laura hellmuth tweeting this for the
first time in the 175-year
history of scientific american we are
endorsing a political candidate
please vote for joe biden to support
science
health the environment evidence-based
policy and
reality over disinformation
well i am joined tonight from washington
d.c by laura hellmuth editor-in-chief
at scientific america lori it's good
it's good to have you on the show we're
happy you're with us um this evening
before we talk about your decision to
endorse joe biden
we want to remind viewers of of what the
u.s president has been saying i want you
to take a listen to an exchange at a
town hall event broadcast on abc
this week and it's probably going to go
away now a lot faster because of the
vaccine it would go away without the
vaccine george
but it's going to go away a lot faster
we'll go away without the vaccine
sure over a period of time sure with
time because many deaths
and you'll develop you'll develop hurt
like a herd mentality it's going to be
it's going to be
herd developed and that's going to
happen that will all happen
but with the vaccine i think it will go
away very quickly
all right so that's just one example and
it's not he meant herd
immunity not herd mentality but we were
wondering today
how do you agree to change of 175-year
policy was there a particular
moment in this presidency when you
thought okay
now we have to say something
yeah it's not a decision we took lightly
you don't break 175 years of tradition
without a really good cause when we came
together as an editorial team about
three months ago to discuss our election
plans
um every it was all hands everybody came
together
we talked through it and it was
unanimous and it was
we pretty quickly came to agreement that
trump has been just so catastrophic for
science
throughout his administration but
particularly during the global pandemic
that we can't be silent that we have to
show what we know and stand up for
reality was it was it was it the
pandemic then the coronavirus is that
the you know the straw that broke the
camel's back for you
yeah although i think you know even
without the coronavirus pandemic
um given how how you know he pulled the
united states out of the paris climate
accord
he's trying to withdraw from the world
health organization um he's
just been you know devastated the
federal science force
his travel bans have interfered with
international collaborations
um so he's he's really been harming the
process of science in the united states
and around the world
throughout his administration but i
think that the pandemic
shows just the deadly consequences of
having policies that are based on
fantasies
and rejection of expertise yeah we've
got more than 190 000
people dead just in the united states
you write that trump has damaged the u.s
um do you believe that
president joe biden would be able to
repair
that damage yeah i think so and
and i think it should be his top
priority i mean obviously there there
has been
just a lot of damage in a lot of ways
that from the trump administration
um but i think you know if if biden wins
and if he comes in
committed to restoring um you know the
science foundation
uh restoring you know experts
weighing in on all the big policy
decisions facing us
he starts to take climate change
seriously take the pandemic seriously
i think those are his most urgent issues
there's been some criticism of your
decision
the the author and evolutionary
psychologist jeffrey miller
tweeted some things today he tweeted
that scientific american
gives up all pretense of scientific
objectivity betrays its historical
principles and goes
full partisan just for some cheap
short-term virtue signaling
let me ask you laura are you
politicizing science with your decision
uh we don't think so i mean this isn't a
legitimate defense if there's like a
school room fight but
we didn't start it i mean trump's the
one who's been politicizing science
who's uh you know been been claiming
that the virus was a hoax claiming that
climate change is a hoax
and sharing conspiracy theories about
you know really important things that we
actually have scientific evidence about
so from our perspective you know he's
the one who's politicizing science by
by calling you know by misrepresenting
it and rejecting it
and you know it's scientific american we
consider it our mission to kind of show
how the world works
which you know in better times is
talking about how black holes work or
evolution or viruses but we feel like it
was
part of our mission and our
responsibility really to say
given our expertise in in the enterprise
of science
we can say really clearly based on the
evidence from the trump administration
that he's not qualified
and joe biden would be so much better
for the us and for the world
have you have you acted too late lord do
you wish that you had um
made this decision earlier
yeah so in in 2016 when trump was a
candidate
a scientific american we ran an
editorial saying
that he has shown a disdain or contempt
for science
and that any world leader needs to just
as a bare minimum
accept reality accept evidence you know
be you know open to
uh scientific findings and so at that
point we came very close to saying
don't vote for trump but we didn't make
that next step and say do vote for
hillary clinton
and then his administration has just
been even worse than we expected
even worse than we warned and so this
time we felt like we needed to make that
final step and say really here's who you
need to vote for if you care about
science
you know it seems like we have two
developments going on here we've got
trump's attacks on science
and we've got you know a part of the
public and its willingness to reject
science
you can vote trump out of office at the
ballot box you cannot change the minds
of masses of people as
easily or as quickly what do you
say to that yeah it's it's a it's a real
problem
surveys especially by the pew research
foundation they've been finding it kind
of a growing polarization
in in acceptance of science or respect
for science
and it used to not be that way you know
science used to have
really strong bipartisan support and
it's really been a few wedge
issues climate change is the top one
where
um there's been just a disinformation
campaign where people have tried to
undermine the science and say it's all a
conspiracy and
you know scientists and journalists are
all part of some cabal and we're
somehow making money off of client
climate change and i mean
none of us want climate change we would
all be delighted if it was somehow an
error in the data
but we see every day in wildfire in
hurricanes
in temperature records that it's not a
fluke and it's not made up it's
happening now and it's already harming
people
do you think lord that um the situation
would be better
for everybody concerned if we had more
scientists
going into politics
i think so and i i hope that more
scientists
get involved and i think a lot of them
have been moved to do so
we have an organization called i think
the 314 project which is for the first
digits of pi
3.14 and um their scientists run for
local state and federal uh office
there aren't very scientists who are
involved in politics and
we think um we just think it would help
a lot
yeah i mean it'll be interesting to see
um there's plenty of attorneys
in politics i think maybe a good dose of
science would do everybody
some good laura helmuth editor-in-chief
at the magazine scientific american lord
we appreciate your time tonight thank
you very much for taking the time to
talk with us and get your story out
thank you so much appreciate it